ukrainian president vladimir zelinsky is
accusing moscow
of carrying out genocide amid russia's
rapid advance in two key regions of
eastern ukraine on friday the ukrainian
military fended off eight russian
attacks in the donbass region destroying
tanks and armored vehicles in the attack
but it also acknowledged they are
outgunned ukrainian forces may have to
retreat from their latest pocket of
resistance in luhansk
mts taya is in the central ukrainian
city of crevie re this morning mtis good
morning
jeff good morning to you well president
zielinski is not the only one accusing
russia of committing genocide here in
ukraine so too are 30
international human rights lawyers and
global human rights campaigners
it's the local police enlisted chance to
have the grim task of burying the dead
this mass grave is filled with dozens of
bodies wrapped in plastic
victims of russia's brutal assault
officer danilo barbaluk says i think the
russians are dogs they don't even
understand what they're doing but there
will be revenge a million times over
30 independent experts say moscow's
atrocities across ukraine show a quote
intent to destroy the ukrainian people
saying russia has incited
a genocide
as russian forces advance on this city
the police are trying to get out anyone
who remains like 74 year old katrina who
says she spends her days living in fear
the kremlin is now throwing nearly all
its fire power at the donbass with this
ukrainian soldier barely surviving a
mortar attack
[Music]
an estimated ten thousand russian troops
are targeting the eastern region from
three sides the province of luhans will
likely soon fall under their control but
ukrainian forces say they'll keep
fighting and it's weapons like this they
plan to win with
these american-made howitzers they
shoot further move faster and can be
hidden very easily
ukraine currently has around 85 of the
108 promised by the u.s the pentagon
says it's also sending high mobility
artillery rocket systems to aid the
fight lieutenant colonel sergey zaika is
the lead trainer here why are howitzers
so important in this fight
these howitzers let us hit the enemy
behind the front lines he says even
inside their trenches
now ukraine has said that it will do
everything it can to defend the donbass
including considering strategic retreats
from certain areas to ensure that its
forces are not encircled michelle
mtas thank you